[Musique]
le guichet unique pour les formalités
d'entreprise et destinées à simplifier
le parcours de création d'entreprise en
offrant d'une part un interlocuteur
unique Limpy qui traite ensuite avec
tous les partenaires les greffes les
organismes consulaires l'INSEE pour
l'utilisateur c'est un seul
interlocuteur et puis c'est une
procédure entièrement dématérialisée qui
lui permet aussi de suivre son dossier
au fil des étapes
[Musique]
dans nos territoires nous avons été
beaucoup sollicités par les entreprises
par les Chambres de commerce par les
Chambres de métiers à propos du guichet
unique nous est remonté aussi que les
interlocuteurs
n'étaient pas dans la possibilité de
répondre ou renvoyer à une adultérieure
une forme de réponse un nouveau système
comme celui-là induit beaucoup de
changements d'abord parce que on fait
tous des matérialiser alors qu'il y
avait encore 60% de démarches sous forme
papier jusqu'à présent et puis on change
les habitudes parce qu'on supprime tous
les CERFA les formulaires type donc
c'est un très très grand changement et
bien entendu il va falloir quelques
semaines pour que tout le monde prenne
ses marques
c'était dans la loi pacte et c'est une
déclinaison d'un texte législatif que
nous avons voté et donc c'était
important de voir comment ça
s'appliquait et puis par ailleurs de
pouvoir avoir des réponses au
questionnement à peu près 100 de des
chefs d'entreprise et des champs
consulaires que nous pouvons rencontrer
sur nos territoires
[Musique]